I want to show you a clip of theovon
with sha Strickland so Shan Strickland
is the current UFC middleweight champion
and in a podcast with the two of them he
talks about some trauma that he's been
through in his past you know what I'm
talking about huh yeah have you ever
heard
that yeah I'm sorry
bud so a man
I'm sorry buddy we don't have talk man I
can just sit here with you for a
minute oh [__] I
think it's one the hard things that
people don't understand like trauma you
know yeah what do you see when you look
at that oh I I see a real vulnerable
moment moment for somebody really
vulnerable moment uh and um
yeah I think childhood trauma is I think
probably the biggest uh trauma for many
people to overcome because uh children
their brain waves are very slow I mean
um in Alpha in in Theta and uh
information goes in very quickly right
into their subconscious and and I think
that um we figure out adaptive ways uh
to not have to feel those emotions or
not have to look at that past but it's
we're always aware of it it's always
there right but but we don't really have
a moment where we fully allow ourselves
to experience it and and I think he had
a moment uh where by association um he
let himself be vulnerable which I think
is great that video is every single time
I watch it is very difficult to watch
for me and it's twofold it's first off
someone that's become a profession hard
person right he just punches people in
the face he likes violence him opening
up and him struggling and then Theo
saying it's okay man we don't need to
talk we can just sit here for a while if
you want I can't it's it's so beautiful
yeah there's and I and I think um
uncertainty and I think that moment of
vulnerability needs space I think it
needs space um and it needs time uh for
the person to sit in that and allows to
fully feel it right and and that's how
that's how it you you sit in it long
enough it goes
away it finally goes away what's your
advice for somebody playing the Theo
role someone's having a conversation
with somebody else who is on the verge
of opening up they're on the cusp of of
feeling something uncomfortable or
trying to open up about it how can
someone hold space more effectively oh I
think I think all people really want to
do is feel safe and feel loved you know
so again I think he played that really
really well and that is just let that
person know that they're that you're
there for them and and give them uh the
room to go as far as they want to go and
and and some people uh uh feel really
safe when that happens and I think they
they they release it you mentioned
before about this uh discomfort with
feeling feelings um we live in a world
which is very good at distracting us
from feeling feelings that are a whole
host of drugs philosophies Technologies
ways of thinking that can distract us
away from feeling feelings and if
there's somebody that's listening to
this and thinking to themselves I don't
think I'm feeling my feelings that
Folly how can someone get back in the
rhythm of feeling their feelings again
yeah you got to sit with yourself you're
going to take your device and set it in
the other room you're going to shut it
off and feel without about that thing
and you got a thing for yourself and I
think um the the that kind of
art of
contemplation um has been lost because I
think that process of
self-reflection kind of is a building
process neurologically in in our brains
and so to to to you know we joke all the
time with people who go through a
weeklong event I say to them when's the
last time you sat with you this long
till you finally like you you have you
sit with yourself long enough um those
feelings are going to come up they're
they will come up because uh um you have
nothing to do you have nothing to do uh
your inner world and how you're thinking
and how you're feeling is going to
become very obvious to you um and so I
think um people ask all the time well
well why is my health condition like
this what do I what are the thoughts
what are the feelings that I need to
change it's really simple sit with
yourself and you'll you'll know exactly
what it is that you that you need to
change so um I I think it's I think you
got to create the time to invest in
yourself um one of the things that I've
discovered with many people that tell us
uh stories of
transformation is that they kind of have
this kind of belief like I believe this
stuff works um I just never believed it
could work for me I mean that's a really
really fundamentally key moment in a
person's Evolution because
that means they actually have to change
their
belief and that's sometimes that means I
got to come out of the resting state and
they got to choose themselves every day
I see that with a lot of things that
that's something that's nice but for
other people that's something which I
believe could be true the data seems to
be to be true but that's not for me yeah
the weight loss isn't for me the
transformation isn't for me the
relationship that's healthy isn't for me
the
group of friends that genuinely want the
best for me Isn't for me
this it's like solipsism in a way it's
persistent
disbelief yes but only around you of
course but but all there is is you so so
that person then who's who's arguing for
some limitation just doesn't believe
that they can change their life they
don't believe that their thoughts have
something to do with their destiny they
don't believe they don't believe in
possibility because they don't believe
in themselves you cannot believe in
possibility without believing in
yourself and you can't if you believe in
yourself that means you got to believe
in possibility and that means then uh
that means you got to do something you
got to get off the couch you know you
got to get up and you got to get engaged
uh in your world and you got to be a
Creator in your life in in and instead
of a victim in your life now that's an
easy thing to say um but it means that
means you have to carve out some time
for you I mean and you invest in
yourself invest in yourself and invest
in your future do it and get
uncomfortable and know that that's
normal that's natural that's the unknown
okay if you if I keep making the same
choices I'm going to keep having the
same health condition if I keep doing
the same things I'm going to still have
the same level of abundance okay so I
got to start making changes it's not
that hard to do it if you really want to
do it I mean if you really want to do it
then you you'll invest in yourself now
for me I think everybody to some degree
Chris believes that they have a hand in
creating their life unless they've had a
really really horrible childhood in past
but on some level people believe it
right so people say well yeah okay so I
I believe that I can get the car I can
get the vacation I can get the new home
I can get the relationship I can get the
second home I don't know whatever it is
that people want but but the way they're
going to do it is okay I'm going to work
really hard I'm going to study a lot
there's nothing wrong with this by the
way um I'm going to be trained uh I'm
going to learn I'm going to make a bunch
of wrong choices I'm going to learn from
my mistakes and then I'm going to get
really good at Gathering a lot of things
and doing these things okay I've created
a certain degree in my life but people
who really really start shortening the
distance between the thought of what
they want and experience of having it
something changes they may say oh I have
the belief that I create my my life in
some way but is it possible that it's
more than the synchronicity you know
more than the parking space more than
thinking of a friend and they call you
like everybody kind of accepts that as
kind of oh that's possible well why
don't take it to the next level I mean
what what if there what if you could
actually do more of that like is that a
belief that you can begin to uh Embrace
so that means if you believe that on
some level that you can create something
greater of like of Greater magnitude of
Greater amplitude um that means then
you'd have to get involved in the
experience a little bit more that means
I'd have to believe how how could I
possibly do that like what would it take
for me to do that and so people evolve
their belief around creation when they
start seeing bigger synchronicities
happen in their life like the
opportunity the the the job the the the
phone call the synchronicity The
Coincidence that's bigger than the
parking space because they're investing
in themselves now here's the cool part
the moment they have that synchronicity
and it has something to do with what
they're doing inside of them they're
going to pay attention to what they did
inside of them they're going to do it
again they're going to believe now oh I
actually am the creator of my life I'm
I'm no longer the victim of my life keep
practicing that over time keep getting
better at it you don't have to go
anywhere and do anything to get things
somehow they seem to come to you somehow
the opportunity is coming to you and
you're not having to do it
now that's another way to create and and
that we're all creators so taking time
to be a Creator taking time to invest in
yourself taking time to get involved in
the experiment this is an experiment to
see to measure the effects of you it
cost right so do it really good one way
and then find out a way if there's a way
to flow if there's a way to change that
all of a sudden allows your environment
to uh change around you uh when you
change that's when the experiment gets
exciting in other news this episode is
brought to you by element stop having
coffee first thing in the morning you're
a Denine system that caffeine acts on
isn't even active for the first 90
minutes of the day but your adrenal
system is and salt acts on your adrenal
system it tastes phenomenal it's the way
that I've started my day for over 3
years now and this orange salt in a cold
glass of water first thing in the
morning is like beautiful nectar it is
my favorite way to start the day it
helps to regulate my appetite it curbs
cravings and it improves my brain
function you might not actually be that
tired you might just be dehydrated an
element is going to help best of all
there is a no b s no questions asked
refund policy you can buy this box
completely risk-free try it all and if
you do not like it they will give you
your money back and you don't even need
to return the box that's how confident
they are that you love it head to the
link in the description below or go to
drink LM nt.com slod wisdom for a free
sample pack of all eight flavors with
your first box that's drink LM nt.com
slod
wisdom thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that clip with Joe you
will love the L 3our long podcast in all
its Glory right here go on give it a tap